was tut die NATO zum Schutz der Ostsee
unter auf und über Wasser wir sind im
Cockpit eines Militär Airbus im Luftraum
über Vorpommern plötzlich sind sie da
Kampfjets auf Backbord mit 20 Metern
Abstand bei 660 km/h
darf ich eine Frage stellen
das ist Formationsflug das lernst du im
Pilotentraining das ist zuerst nicht
einfach aber wenn du es drauf hast ist
es wie Schwimmen oder Radfahren du
kannst das mit geschlossenen Augen
der Pilot im Airbus zieht Schleifen über
Schäfchen Wolken zusammen mit deutschen
Eurofightern einer zeigt was er unter
dem Flügel hat es ist eine Warnung ein
abfangeinsatz eine Übung für den Fall
dass sein Pilot keine Position sendet
nicht auf Funk reagiert also offenbar
unentdeckt bleiben will
den Ernstfall filmt erst im Juni ein
britischer Pilot
in der Bildmitte russische
Militärflugzeuge rechts ein Jet of
Schweden sie fliegen über der Ostsee an
der Grenze zum nato-lufttraum und
trennen sich erst als die Russen
abtreten
Abfangmanöver fliegen beide Seiten seit
Jahren und über alle Meer
drohen nun auch über der Ostsee
gefährliche Flugbewegungen wie diese
im Airbus fliegen wir einmal rund um die
Ostsee der Belgier Harold van P hat den
Befehl über die NATO Kampfjets im Norden
der Ostflanke wir nähern uns der
russischen Enklave Kaliningrad und die
staune wie gesittet die Umgangsformen in
diesem Luftraum sind
es bräuchte doch nur einen kleinen
Pilotenfehler und dann gäbe seinen
Eskalation die keiner wollte
passieren aber wir wollen das vermeiden
wenn die Russen zum Beispiel einen
alarmeinsatz fliegen dann lassen wir
unsere Jets auch mal am Boden
[Musik]
sie sollen sich nicht in die Quere
kommen gerade vor Kaliningrad wollen wir
keine Missverständnisse und die auch
nicht wir haben über der Ostsee noch
einen gutes Arbeitsverhältnis mit den
Russen ich will dass es so bleibt
Ortswechsel ein Reporter
zwei Soldaten
im Hafen von Wenz Pilz in Lettland
und wir kommen jetzt langsam wieder
zurück zur Plattform
als erstes Medium dürfen wir zeigen was
die NATO zum Schutz kritischer
Infrastruktur unter Wasser tut der
Bedarf ist da
denn im September 2022 explodieren
Sprengsätze in den Röhren der Nord
Stream Pipelines es ist ein hybrider
Meeresgrund die Täter sind unbekannt die
Untersuchung läuft auch mit Amtshilfe
der deutschen Marine
[Musik]
unser Ziel ist die Rottweil ein
deutsches Minentaucher Einsatzboot
unterwegs vor Lettland im Auftrag der
NATO
zwei Tage und zwei Nächte werden wir
Teil der Besatzung sein 38 Mann vier
Frauen
corvettenkapitän Oliver Kiesling ist 32
Jahre alt und im ersten Einsatz als
Kommandant
Wolfram ist der erste wach Offizier zum
Schutz der Soldaten nennen wir keine
Nachnamen er ist Minentaucher seine
Ausrüstung ist seine Lebensversicherung
jeder Terror selber für sein Material
verantwortlich also das macht auch der
Kommandant noch selber gemacht
[Musik]
Taucher sind Experten für alles was
unter Wasser explodieren kann
diese Mine ist harmlos das Szenario aber
ist es nicht ein explosives Objekt liegt
in der Nähe kritischer Infrastruktur die
Taucher sollen es anheben und verlagern
diese hebel-verfahren sind immer dann
relevant wenn wir Munition Objekte
sprengobjekte oder Altlasten in
Bereichen finden wo wir sie nicht
sprengen können und das ist in der Regel
im direkten Einzugsbereich von
unterseekabeln pipeline's oder anderen
sage ich mal kritischen oder sensiblen
Objekten
sie schieben die übungsmine über Bord
wuchten Technik in ein Beiboot ein
gelbes Paket mit Gasflaschen das noch
wichtig wird
Minentaucher wie Wolfram gehören zu den
Spezialkräften der Bundeswehr 54 Meter
Tiefe das ist ihre Grenze doch im
ostsee-grün schimmert schnell rot weiß
der Taucher stellt sicher dass die Mine
nicht explosiv ist und befestigt ein
Stahlseil die Technik macht
zeitverzögert den Rest
denn das gelbe Paket entpuppt sich als
hebeballon der einmal aufgeblasen
Auftrieb gibt
so kann jedes Objekt von kritischer
Infrastruktur entfernt werden ob eine
Mine oder ein Sprengsatz
die Marine hat also die Fähigkeiten aber
sie hat auch andere Aufgaben darum
müssen die Betreiber Pipelines und Kabel
auch selber schützen es gibt ein
gemeinsames Interesse daran also sowohl
im militärischen Bereich wie auch im
privaten und in wirtschaftlichen Sektor
für den Schutz der kritischen
einfrastruktur zu sorgen oder dazu
beizutragen
wissen ist Macht im Hybriden Krieg wer
ist wo auch sie was liegt auf dem
Meeresgrund es braucht ein Lagebild und
die Marine leistet einen Beitrag auch
der ist gelb Remus eine schwimmende
Drohne schickt Schallwellen auf den
Meeresgrund die Daten werden über Nacht
ausgelesen
Piloten strampeln und rennen beim
alarmeinsatz zählt jede Sekunde
Kampfjets aus Rumänien auf dem
Stützpunkt schaulei in Litauen
jede dieser F16 muss innerhalb von 15
Minuten in der Luft sein das ist die
Vorgabe das üben sie
die Nato will der Welt zeigen sie
schützt hier den Luftraum
das Geschwader ist gerade für vier
Monate da der Chef hört auf den Kampf
Namen mitza
the generell feeling when
das Gefühl im echten Einsatz ist nochmal
ganz anders als im Training aber sobald
wir in der Luft sind und wir unsere
geübten Abläufe umsetzen dann fühlt es
sich gut an man fühlt sich richtig wohl
wie oft wird es echt wie oft fangen sie
Flugzeuge ab
10 Alarm einsetzen oder auch mehr und
dann steigen wir wieder eine Woche gar
nicht auf es kommt wirklich darauf an
es kommt an auf die NATO auf Russland
und darauf dass beide Seiten kühle Köpfe
bewahren in der Luft
[Applaus]
und auf dem Wasser zurück zur Rottweil
und dem Hauptauftrag der Minentaucher es
ist viertel nach fünf die Nacht ist
vorbei das Müsli muss irgendwie runter
die frühstückslektüre
sind grobe Pixel vom Meeresgrund
Steine Reifen Rohre kann alles mögliche
sein
die Frage wollen Sie klären und es ist
keine Übung
sie schicken einen Roboter auf den
Meeresgrund seine Kamera blickt in 15
Meter Tiefe
zurück an Bord Auswertung das Baltikum
war umkämpft den beiden Weltkriegen und
diese Kugeln sind tatsächlich stumme
Zeugen russische Bauart 115 Kilo
Sprengstoff entwickelt vor über 100
Jahren
da ist es grundsätzlich theoretisch
möglich bis heute dass die bei der
falschen Handhabung gerade bei Kontakt
immer noch umsetzen
die Minen sollen umsetzen aber bitte
kontrolliert mit Zündkabel und mit rosa
Sprengstoff eingepackt in Mülltüten
Wolfram der Taucher wird den Sprengsatz
an der Miene platzieren
was jetzt nicht nervös wenn sie wissen
dass das Dinger hochgehen kann
mit dem Sprengsatz in der Hand taucht er
ab ist aber schnell zurück
sie werden es wieder versuchen
am nächsten Morgen ist die Lage so ruhig
wie die See aber das ändert sich
daher
Kommandant Oliver Kießling löst Alarm
aus jeder muss jetzt auf seine Position
das Szenario ein Boot nähert sich in
feindseliger Absicht
es sieht wie Hektik aus ist aber Routine
der Kapitän verlässt die Brücke
gibt von Unterdeck hinter Panzerstahl
seine Befehle
Zustand
Abwehrbereitschaft endet ist das Ziel
dieser Übung
es kann immer schneller sein
die Übung ist Teil eines Manövers dass
die NATO jedes Jahr abhält neu sind
Kontext und Dimension 50 Schiffe samt
Fluggerät 19 NATO-Staaten plus
Beitrittskandidat Schweden
es sind Muskelspiele zweier nachtblöcke
denn auch russlandsflotte fährt zur
gleichen Zeit wenige Seemeilen weiter
ihre Geschütze auf
die Rottweil gehört zur Speerspitze der
NATO an der Ostflanke der Kommandant
bestätigt russisches Militär käme oft in
Sichtweite er nennt es gegenseitige
Wachsamkeit
ja
und zwar regelmäßig aber immer so dass
mit einem ordentlichen Abstand
voneinander operiert wird
Abstand ist relativ in der Luft sind es
oft nur wenige Meter die NATO fliegt
derzeit häufiger über der Ostsee der
Airbus schafft dafür Reichweite als
fliegende Tankstelle mit bis zu 32
Tonnen Kerosin in jedem Flügel
unten Schwedens Küste oben Schwedens
Luftwaffe das Land war neutral nähert
sich aber buchstäblich der NATO an der
Beitritt zum Bündnis ist noch nicht
endgültig Schweden aber ist schon NATO
kompatibel so wird Russland Spielraum in
der Ostsee kleiner ich frage general
major van p
ret wie drei Jahrzehnte lang war das
eine ruhige Gegend ändert sich das jetzt
durch den Beitritt von Finnland und
hoffentlich bald auch von Schweden
verschieben sich die Gewichte ein wenig
aber bei dieser NATO-Mission da machen
wir eigentlich dasselbe wie in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten für sich
genommen hat sie sich nicht verändert
in meinen Ohren ist das auch anders
Statement der Auftrag ist der alte das
Umfeld ist neu die Ostsee wird zunehmend
ein NATO mehr dagegen steht Moskaus
macht ein Spruch und das wirkt
[Musik]
die taucherräumen Reste vergangener
Konflikte Minensuche ist eine
Geduldsprobe eine
Generationenaufgabe auch der neue Krieg
kennt die alten Mine
und das Interessante ist dass die Minen
die heute zum Beispiel im Schwarzen Meer
eingesetzt worden ganz oft immer noch
genauso historische Minen sind wie es
eben damals auch sind also wir haben es
ganz häufig bei der Menü Munition die
dort eingesetzt ist auch mit Minen zu
tun die wir heute hier noch suchen und
schließlich finden
Explosionen unter Wasser diese Bilder
erinnern an Nord Stream
ihre Botschaft ist eine völlig andere
der neue Krieg in Europa stellt die NATO
von neuer Aufgaben
gegen Ende dieser Reise werden wir
erfahren was das für deutsche Soldaten
heißt die Rottweil geht auf Heimatkurs
nach vielen Häfen in Nord- und Ostsee
heißt das Ziel Kiel die Vorfreude wächst
die Strapazen sind fast geschafft
gegen Ende eines Einsatzes merkt man
natürlich so ein bisschen
Menschen sind gereizt sie müssen sich
vorstellen die sind erwachsene Menschen
mit Familien Frauen wie Männer die hier
über fünf Monate in sechs manchmal acht
Mann sechs zusammen gehaust haben ich
glaube alle freuen sich das jetzt zu
Hause sind auch wieder ein bisschen
Privatsphäre haben ja
auf mich wartet meine Frau ja
auf jeden Fall wartet jemand auf die
Taucher und auf die Techniker auf die
Köche die Antwort bitte schön Smoot
heißen und auf den Sanitäter der alle
heil nach Hause bringt
na klar
gerade nach Island war halt sehr schlimm
da gibt's halt Tabletten und dann
kriegen und dann passt das
Emanuel hat keine Tabletten gegen
Heimweh gegen beziehungs- sein
Arbeitgeber denkt beim Stichwort
Lastenteilung eben nicht gleich ein
Familien ist toll finde Familie schön
haben sie auch was davon
bei der Bundeswehr oder hier bei der
Marine
nicht unbedingt immer
nicht in den letzten
155 Tagen Empfang im Marinestützpunkt
auf Emanuel wartet Julia ja also mit den
Kindern das alleine zu sein ist schon
eine Herausforderung für die Frau ist
das natürlich blöd
halt alleine zu Hause und muss das
irgendwie alles alleine sterben ja also
ich finde auch er kann
aber ja man ist natürlich auch stolz auf
den Partner dass er das auch ja das
unterwegs war dass er es geschafft hat
dass er so viel gesehen hat und ja
die Musik ist ein Wunsch des Kapitäns
der Wunsch der Familie und der Soldaten
ist Anerkennung
die deutsche Gesellschaft fremdelt noch
mit ihrer Armee und mit ihren Sound
helging
weil anscheinungsbrücke Liegeplatz 4
Marine festgemacht
Emanuel der Sanitäter dient seit 16
Jahren
während seinen Kommandant in der
Bundeswehr wohl noch Karriere machen
wird hört der 38-Jährige Ende November
auf seine Frau Julia meint es wird
höchste Zeit
ihre Heimkehr ist immer seltener planbar
der Ernstfall dafür immer greifbarer
auch wenn die neuen Krieg in Europa
andere führen
er hat das Leben derer die die Ostsee
schützen heute schon verändert